hey guys welcome to episode 201
of congratulations
[Music]
oh man you know we did it we freaking
did it dude and it's such a good time
man i worked out real hard
um well i'll just go through it with you
man i did lunges i did 200 lunges up my
up
up my uphill street i did it in 17
minutes i try to beat my time that's
what i did
i did it in 20 minutes last time and i
was like i bet i could beat it
really a lot and i did i did it
i did it and i beat it in three minutes
oh and i didn't just do lunges i held
oh i held 45s in each hand
sorry to break your heart strong guys
but i held 45s in each hand
and i did and i did 200
so sorry to break your heart strong guys
so i did it and i did it
in 17 minutes
it's hard to break our heart strong guys
so uh yeah and and that's just kind of
the [ __ ]
silly goose mode we're in right now you
know that made me completely out of
breath because i'm still struggling for
hair from doing that but i also did that
and then what else did i do um i did
wow i forget um
i know i did school oh i did step
throughs bro those will kill you
just where you step forward and then
backwards and forward and backwards and
forward and backwards and forward in
their lunges as well
so your boy was doing so many lunges it
was crazy and um i did those
i did four rounds of that and then i did
four rounds of
uh squats where i just [ __ ] your boy
held 45s hello 45s you're working
overtime today and i held them above
right here
and i just did squattings and then i
[ __ ] dropped one and i did more
squattings and then i dropped two and i
did the last squatting so
okay sorry strong guys so sue me what
are we doing here you know what i mean
so
uh it was it was great and i had a good
workout and i was tired for [ __ ]
three hours
i ate a protein shake and then i ate
some [ __ ] chimken so
it's all good dude uh and it's fun
and i like working out and uh that's it
that's it so thanks for the patreon
you guys you want to if you guys want to
join the patreon
beautiful uh we got a lot of people on
patreon and you get the rest of that
episode on patreon
but also maybe just listen to this on
youtube and preach either way
preach either way so that's great um
and make sure you honestly if you're a
fan of the podcast
subscribe to the [ __ ] page please and
also
if you subscribe why don't you just
[ __ ] roll up against that like button
while you're at it you're already there
you're already there you're already
there
and uh [ __ ] knee knee that
[ __ ] like a kickboxer that uh that's
bell notification button dude ring that
bell notification with that [ __ ] knee
and uh i've i uh yeah
but that's so i don't know dude how
about uh
well how about this and i can't find the
text things but i found it
i i just uh hell yes
[Laughter]
soul board
how do you laugh like that well first of
all you get billions of dollars then you
laugh like that step two laugh like that
step one have billions of dollars step
two laugh like that and
wearing a cowboy hat nothing could be
greater well yes maybe if he's wearing a
space outfit oh he is
oh he is he is wearing a [ __ ] outfit
you wear in a spaceship
and a cowboy hat hey
he is let me rip that bear's repeating
jeff
bezos is laughing like that
wearing a space outfit
and a cowboy hat so when you're in a
space outfit
what do you have on your head well i'll
tell you one of those [ __ ] domes
you got one of those domes that when you
take it off it goes
you go wow man that was a great space
ride
but he doesn't have that well then
you're like well okay well he probably
just has nothing then well no but he
does
he has a cowboy hat
so what where were you going planet
ranch
planet tumbleweed where are you going
planet joe rogan where are you going
where are you going rogan's in austin
where are you going dude
just a planet with a bunch of [ __ ]
horses on it i'm going to bear back them
all
so evil dude the way he laughs hell yes
[Laughter]
so much breath in his laugh unbelievable
dude so much breath
and his laugh if i was the news i would
yeah yeah cool and
i would have been like that like someone
was squirting squirting a water bottle
in my face
dude i can't believe his spaceship
looks like a [ __ ]
dude jeff pesos jeff bezos
your space craft
looks like a giant
horny [ __ ]
[Music]
how did that happen you meant to do it
all good ementa and i know
you meant to because once you saw the
blueprints and the plans
the only thing anybody around it would
say
is hey look it's a huge hornet [ __ ]
so it's shooting into outer space and
he's just in a cowboy hat
laughing with billions of dollars unreal
dude
in a giant [ __ ] oh
all the amazon workers just [ __ ]
packing boxes and [ __ ] just hot ash
hot as [ __ ] in all hell just working at
9 00 p.m trying to
make shipments i hope
our leader has fun in the [ __ ] in his
big [ __ ]
and he's just on a cowboy just just
horizontal like this sitting
with a cowboy hat on
uh they shake so much in the [ __ ] in
in blast-offs
they shake so much dude
dude the best thing would be if you
heard somebody blasting off you know
that
you know what i always wanted to [ __ ]
hear is i wanted a drummer to be miked
and only listen to what the drummer is
saying while
a band is playing because you know that
they're [ __ ] killing it but you know
they're just like
and that's so funny to me and that's it
dude
and that's the kind of [ __ ] that i think
of
[Music]
[ __ ] basos wasn't a [ __ ] blasting off
bean zones
jeff being something can't glance on a
[ __ ] rocket ship
um with a cowboy hat with a flamboyant
bat
why are you in a cowboy hat with a
flamboyant man in a space suit jay's
room
and i can't get a rocket ship um it's
unbelievable dude
i can't believe what's better than that
clip dude hell yes
[Laughter]
we honestly didn't [ __ ] even
talk about the hell yes
because the laugh was so overshadowing
now let's go back
what we do is we watch clips we single
out the most
uh moment and then after that
sometimes we're forgetful but sometimes
we go back
no we have to go back the strongest
moment of the clip
was the laugh match okay
the strongest over most overshadowing
moment in that clip
was the laugh it's like
in that new king kong godzilla movie
when the [ __ ] airplane
landed on king kong's chest when he was
dead and they exploded him to [ __ ]
make his heart go again
natch that's the most wow moment
how did that get past everybody how did
this guy live
55 years however many years and
get to the point in his life where
that's his laugh
okay after something he said
i don't like to say this a lot because
it's ingrained in internet culture now
but goals okay
the confidence of the helies
could only be somebody with eight
billion dollars
well yes you know or or a homeless guy
or a homeless guy or a guy on the street
that's just like
you know jesus is coming really well yes
with rags on or space outfit
and cowboy hat okay so unbelievable hell
yes
so breathy evil hell yes
um so this guy is my idol uh
and that's it dude i can't believe he's
going to space he went to space for like
14 seconds or whatever what'd he do just
[ __ ] pop up and just
and then came back down it's like 2
million dollars a minute or some [ __ ]
wow dude he's divorced you know
by the way he honestly he's a nicholas
cage character to be laughing like that
is unreal
and a cowboy hat dude i'm surprised he
didn't have a [ __ ] eagle on his arm
with i'm surprised honestly it's not he
didn't have an eagle on his arm
and a [ __ ] cat on a leash and then
also the space suit when it zoomed out
it that he didn't have pants on didn't
have pants part of it didn't have pants
it was a [ __ ] dress because he just
doesn't give a [ __ ] like a [ __ ] short
short dress and the answer
the answer the question he's answering
is is that is that a skirt
hell yes
[Laughter]
wow the last are the best he's just
running he's about to pass out
um
calvin's been cool he's been just for no
reason saying die dada
um just for no reason i'll just be in
the room i swear to god and for no
reason they'll just look at me and say
die dada and i'm just like what and
he'll go like this
or some [ __ ] and i'm just like what did
you say and he will no and he won't say
it again for another day i'm just in the
other room and i hear
and i'm just like what did you say and
he's just like
why is my son telling me to die
he doesn't even he says although one
time he came into the room
uh he came into the room hey cooper go
you're going to knock the [ __ ]
camera one time he came into the room
and and when i was
uh waking up he had been up already and
he walked in the room and he just says
hi tata and it was so [ __ ] cute and
ever since then he's been saying
dada so it's all good it's all good man
um
[Music]
unfrickin believable hell yes
dude that's unbelievable die da da cool
i um
dude my did you guys watch the conor
mcgregor fight unreal
unreal and mainly i'm talking about what
is conor mcgregor ever saying i can't
understand him but also
so um that
dustin dude we follow each other
dustin pourier right i always want to
say podiu because it's sydney podie
dustin pourier that guy's a class act
huh he just is he's a class act man
he's got that tattoo on his left [ __ ]
thing
and it's like a saber-tooth tiger
scratched him up
and but he's a class act dude
and uh i like him i'm a fan of him dude
and he's got that hot sauce so i'm gonna
[ __ ] i want to get that hot sauce but
uh
he's uh he's he's a killer dude that guy
just he has poise dude
i love fighters dude because though they
they it's so
funny like how like it because i thought
they were friends him and conor mcgregor
because after the [ __ ] fight
last time when he kicked his leg conor
was limping and afterwards like ah
you're a good lad are you a good ladar
you know
and then he was like thank you thank you
you know he's like ah you really kicked
me like an hour laddie you know
and then he was like yeah uh
great and then all of a sudden kristen's
like
this is gonna be great they hate each
other and i was like they're like
they're friends and she was like really
and i'm like
yeah dude they're friends and then it
was like a pre-show
thing and dustin was like i'm gonna kill
that [ __ ] because [ __ ] him
because what he said
and then i'm like what is what is the
thing that happened
because something has happened right
and i didn't know what it was until
after the f we all know what happened he
broke his [ __ ] leg
and his his his uh leg look like a
[ __ ] spaghetti noodle
and and then dustin was like
you know what everything was cool until
he said he was gonna murder me
like dude fighters are hilarious that
they'll just get
locked on this one thing that when
you're like that's crossing the line
he said he was gonna murder me and that
was it that was the thing i couldn't
i couldn't take anymore say whatever you
want
say you're gonna [ __ ] my wife's mouth do
not say you're gonna murder me
it's not cool man there's no coming back
from that he said like it's so weird you
know what he's you know what dude you
know what made me lose
do you guys used to be friends what
happened well fighters will be like you
know what
he said i couldn't make a roast beef
sandwich and honestly that's where i'm
gonna draw the line
because i know to use middle bread i'm
gonna kick his [ __ ] ass
really yup that's what it is
he said i couldn't make roast beef
sandwich but i got all jews for day
okay i get all jews for day and i say
day
because the s is selling on days because
oh you the ssl nanju so
go [ __ ] yourself man esses are silent
are you losing your mind
yep
are you losing your mind yeah are you
saying
yeah because the s is silent and yes i
lost my mind i've
been hit too many times in the [ __ ]
head look at my ears looks like i have
earphones on right
yeah no i don't
it's cauliflower ear just one nope
two you know why i yeah because i said
okay cool
moon walks out of there fighters are
crazy dude
i didn't like what he said really yeah
he said it would take too long to put
something together from ikea i didn't
like what he said
that was the thing that you know what
and and it was cool man it was cool when
he said he was going to drag my wife and
family over hot coals
i can deal with that but when he said i
can't put together a mom
m-a-l-m that's something at ikea when i
can't put together a mom quick enough
that was it that's where i draw the line
that's when i knew i was gonna win
and that's why i stuck my whole arm in
his [ __ ] during the fight that's why
i did that because i wanted him to
experience the same pain
that i felt when he said i can't put
together a mom
he said i couldn't get i couldn't find
the exit out of target
that's what he said he said he could get
out of the target quicker than i can
when i know i've been there way more
many times with my wife than he has with
his
so i can handle him saying that he's
going to [ __ ] send my
wife 900 monkeys
and have to deal with that until she
calls animal control
but i can't deal with i get out of
target quit [ __ ]
and that's why i secretly brought this
machete shetty and lopped off his head
during the fight
yeah fighters dude that's like it's so
[ __ ]
hey always with the [ __ ] what am i am
i
there there was a war in my high school
armenians versus
koreans versus whites and it was just
hilarious you never knew what the [ __ ]
was that was gonna piss everybody off
right
like white got like like arm
like you couldn't talk about an asian's
car [ __ ] it no no
[ __ ] it you could not talk about an
asian car hey that acura what is it five
years old
hey what'd you say oh no i was just i'm
just making a joke
why is this knife in me
armenians you never knew dude
seriously that's not cool to joke around
about that
and white dudes you just make you like
if you made fun of their [ __ ]
the way they dressed or any really who
knows white guys are [ __ ] absolutely
the ones that'll kill you and murder
your whole family
because they're just so secretly just
[ __ ]
mad
you know being because white is like
was like the you know everybody was
white everybody in power was white and
now or
i guess they still are but i don't know
i have no [ __ ] clue i haven't read
the news in nine years but um
so they had nothing to be mad about but
they were secretly mad about the [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you know they'd be walking
around just like yeah everything's cool
but then you do something they get such
red so red-faced
you know but uh hey you know the asians
in our school or the
armenians in our school they would just
wear it the mexicans you knew
what was up they were just like bro
we're just [ __ ] hey
move on dog
[Laughter]
move on man move on man you don't want
it you don't want to [ __ ] with us dog
we're like yeah i kind of believe that
hey man
it's all good right
whatever dude
to the break of dawn baby
that conor mcgregor fight was [ __ ]
crazy he got his [ __ ]
ankle i was texting my buddy who's a a
martial artist and he was like
it's over for him man it's so [ __ ]
you're so [ __ ] with that injury
you break your ankle or whatever shin
and you're just like
it's such long rehab and then you gotta
first of all the pain lasts a long time
then you gotta rehab it
that's a long time and then you gotta
like go through
in your head i i bet it it [ __ ] your
head up almost rub
i bet that [ __ ] your head up though
dude like you're just like oh i
you know i i i know so he's at the age
where he's like can i still do it
uh i don't even want to [ __ ] think
about that but you know what he's got
[ __ ] 900 million dollars so who cares
bro i would take a broken leg for that
much money
[ __ ] all that god that must hurt [ __ ]
all that though
i'm gonna do i'm gonna i gotta read my
[ __ ] tick tock comments dude this is
unbelievable i did this once
last uh a few episodes ago and it was
great and i just gotta
i just got it dude i put up a tick tock
first of all follow me on tick tock tick
tock
is the oh look at this ambitions
this is the first thing that popped up
did this moment motivate you to push
deeper into the cosmos
hell yes
i mean this is on tick tock just when i
pulled it up dude they're listening
ambitions this is absolutely
uh listening to us so that's cool phones
are listening to us so i put up a tick
tock
dude this whole the whole what are you
gonna do if
[ __ ] well you d w w y
d is my favorite what do you do if
we walk into a cvs and i go like this
what are you gonna do and then people
will just be like this is what i do
but there's like this what you doing if
we break in to your house
uh trend and people are just like
pretending to walk through doors and
[ __ ]
but nobody's walking through the door
like they're gonna break into the
[ __ ] house
they're just walking through the door
all sexy and [ __ ]
like bro these guys these two big ass
dudes come in
and they're just like what you doing if
we break into your house
and they just like like this and they
walk in
and then the one guy goes
and you're just like i'm telling you i
don't want to [ __ ] if you walk into my
house like that
this trend dude so i put up this thing
these dudes walk into this the house and
i and i reacted to it i
it was a joke i was hiding behind my my
my son my
who's 17 months you know and your boy
goes crazy viral so it's just [ __ ]
your boy goes [ __ ] not so viral
you know you your boy he's dot-com your
boy
goes hard
in [ __ ] viral city i'll just say that
your boy goes
absolutely bonk nation in [ __ ] up
dude it's unreal how
[ __ ] i get [ __ ]
anyway the comments
because it starts with what are you
gonna do with breaking house i think
some people think i was
somebody wrote there the two black guys
walking in and somebody wrote
literally twins and they were talking
about me and calvin and i wrote just
because they're both black doesn't mean
they look alike
that's funny i did that and that's funny
um
somebody says anyone down to make
friends in the comment section love it
that's great
uh very cool you keeping it real i'll
like that because that was from shupra
um but people when you get lower in the
comments
here i love it when they get serious
dude i mean you're not bulletproof my
guy
yeah yeah yeah okay cool so you're just
gonna shoot the guys i guess all right
all right um somebody writes frisk me
please
uh
and then somebody writes
hit him with the lead
dude i love tough dudes behind the
screen
and his [ __ ] avatar
is a cartoon caterpillar with sunglasses
on
standing in front of saturn
hit him with the lead and his name's
cameron
he's so white
what is this i always get who are you on
my comments just
what do you mean i'm the guy you're
commenting on the [ __ ] page
is that are you are are you trying to is
that some honestly is that something
somebody does
to make you feel try and feel irrelevant
is that what that is yes
one fire said yes dude i don't even get
it
who are you
you know what i always i i like you you
get it
unless you're [ __ ] will smith you get
people i don't even i don't even know
who who you are but my friend it's like
what does that make it you're cooler
because you don't know
i gotta know i i don't know you don't
know who i am so i
i you're cool you're cool for not
knowing
somebody who's who goes [ __ ]
not so viral you're the cool one
cause you don't know what's going on
when your boy goes [ __ ] i go crazy viral
every week
i'm the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's but but
it's like there is like
everybody doesn't know somebody
sorry man oh bro you're irrelevant what
the [ __ ]
okay i don't even who gives a [ __ ] dude
fame [ __ ] sucks anyway
um somebody writes
uh
somebody writes good lord you attract
literal dumpster
trash in your comment section i had no
idea was this bad
it's it's every comment section dude it
all turns to [ __ ]
absolute anger people was just like
everyone shows that they have deeper
issues um
look look look look well you have broken
in so i would have
so i would have to fight win or lose
everyone going home hurting
that's [ __ ] hilarious to actually
think about that if like someone was
trying to fight you and you're like oh
looks like everybody's going home
hurting
[Laughter]
oh looks like everyone's going home
[ __ ] hurting huh
whoever wins it doesn't matter we're
both getting hurt
um
here we go why are
oh yeah this guy is why are all these
people trying to break into my house
which is hilarious because
that's what the like the trend
um
lol the body ain't scaring me tell him
lock the door because today one or all
of us gonna die
jesus christ calling your mama and
letting her know when your funeral is
imagine that dude they walk in hold on
one second guys
what's your mom's number huh
what's your mom's number all right i'll
bite
here it is send it to you okay just give
me one second
[Music]
hello hi okay
so i've got something for you is this
mrs what's your last name
is this mrs johnson yeah
well uh we have a funeral on our hands
in about a week and it's going to be
your son
and his friend who is that oh that's
your brother okay so it's going to be
both of your
both of your sons which ones how many
brothers do you have
four brothers so two of them and it's
gonna be who is it derek and will you
jim
derek and jim so in a week we have ch
oh i i played this way wrong i lied on
tick-tock and this is not what i would
do
turns out because i
so [ __ ] how i just grabbed [ __ ] wong
called it out he went [ __ ] trying to
grab the phone
dude when you lose something under your
desk it's the most [ __ ]
but dude you know what have you ever
done this in school like when you were
in high school and [ __ ] and you're just
chilling and you're like touching under
the desk and you're listening to the
teacher and you're just like cool and
then you realize for [ __ ]
15 minutes you've been fingering some
old gum
you ever do that [ __ ] you're just like
and i guess in your subconscious you're
like that's a screw that just keeps this
desk together
and then you realize why is it a little
soft oh because i'm fingering
someone's gum that's been there for
[ __ ] two years
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do if i'm fingering gum after two years
calling your mom and telling her when
the funeral is
so listen your son carl
two years ago put some gum under the
table and i just want to let you know
that in about a week
you're gonna have to go to his funeral
tick-tock trends bro boy goes
stupid viral on tick tock i
i [ __ ] met guy fieri once dude that's
hilarious
and he was all guy fieri he was just so
guy fieri
you know you see those guys that like
wear the sun you know because god the
guys are who are so themselves
like the guy like guy fury has [ __ ]
flames on his shirt and like always and
just like
sunglasses and spiky hair and he just
had that he had that
where i saw him i had a house
at someone's house he had that
and he was like you're gonna love this
and i'm like what is it
pork belly they're always making like
[ __ ] you're like what people even eat
that
yup oh yeah they do all that are you
crazy they make you feel stupid okay
oh they're gonna love this what's this
duck brain
what they eat this are you crazy
you [ __ ] idiot hell yeah i don't have
flames on the bottom of my shirt for
nothing
oh i don't get the correlation but okay
give me two duck brains please
two here's 40.
with a reduction sauce whatever the [ __ ]
that is everything on them there's
one thing on a menu that has a reduction
sauce i don't know what the [ __ ] that is
when a waiter says and it's you know
nice reductions
i just want to be like you know what
dude just [ __ ] never mind
how about that bring me a goddamn burger
with your [ __ ] reduction saw [ __ ]
what there's less of it what are we
talking about reducing
i don't want it oh man here we go what's
that
dragon eyes what
those exist well how they're gonna see
no i mean dragons
are you kidding me what are you a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa jesus christ
here here's 50 of them eat them all or
you're
it's disrespectful oh my god dude
how are those dragon eyes just a mouth
full of [ __ ] dragon eyes
with [ __ ] barbecue sauce on them this
is so gross
there's one on the floor it's rolling
get it okay
get it with your mouth not your hand you
[ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] jesus christ he hits you
ow i'm guy fieri for no reason
let me put barbecue sauce on the side of
your face
oh my god you're being so disrespectful
so how was last night oh well you know
you're not gonna believe this but
i was at someone's house and guy fieri
was there really
yeah no and that's not it dude he made
me eat [ __ ] duck brains
pork belly and [ __ ] dragon eyes and
then he [ __ ] made me eat him off the
floor and put barbecue sauce on the side
of my face and he called me [ __ ] twice
well it sounds like guy fairy welcome to
burgers dinans and drives or whatever
the [ __ ]
hi i'm guy fieri welcome to burgers
dinings and drives
what did you even think of the name hey
what's up i'm guy fieri welcome to
dragon balls and eyesores and
punk [ __ ] what welcome to but
i'm i'm guy fury welcome to dragon ball
punk source and
what'd i say
punk [ __ ] but what was the source oh
yeah
no eyeballs that [ __ ] it who cares
i'm going back like it's some important
[ __ ] i said
you're a punk [ __ ] aren't you eat this
i'll put my belly on you're just [ __ ]
putting it on your shoulder
all right ah bro i
i uh oh i did twitch with [ __ ]
kristen i did
twitch and we played it takes two and
it's a fun game
didn't realize halfway through that
there was an intro that we didn't even
[ __ ]
look at because it just kind of played
first before we sat down to play and we
didn't know what was going on in the
game
and we played it it's a cool game it was
fun very fun from the makers of that
movie that i talked or movie from the
makers of that video game that i talked
about i mean they're all movies now
anyway with the [ __ ] cut scenes dude
god damn you
can't play a [ __ ] video game with no
cut scene dude i don't want to watch the
cut scenes man
i just want to play the video game i
don't need a [ __ ] scene explaining
some [ __ ] for 30 minutes
alas we play unless we play lest we
forget we still
play okay so i did it and we played it
and it was fun do it a nice bonding
moment
[ __ ] absolute heat rose absolute
got absolutely got hot
[ __ ] doing it like this twisting the
controller and being like baby you got
it baby you got a baby
you got it okay so you jump too soon you
jump too soon and that's why and then i
died too
and so it's like that's me playing a
video game and i'm like supposed to not
be mad
right because everything is not gonna be
her fault okay fine but i still want it
to be
um so everything's not her fault but
want it to be so so now how do we figure
that out right
because i'm a human and i'm a male and
i'm in a relationship so
i want things to be not my fault
um and so we played it and then i think
we're gonna play more games and
my twitch by the way is [ __ ] flex
avenue it's flex avenue dude join me on
twitch it's flex avenue time
dude i'm handsome when i make that face
flex avenue dude
i used to go in my parents bedroom late
at night to try and make him laugh
because
i knew that that was a bad audience
because they wanted to be tired they
wanted to be going to sleep and they'd
be so mad at me i would come in and i
would just do [ __ ] posing
and [ __ ] and i would be like this is
what i would do if i was a bodybuilder
and i would do [ __ ] all sorts of
poses
and my mom always cracked first she'd
start laughing and then my dad would
start laughing
but dude because your boy was lanked out
dude your boy was lanky as [ __ ] dude
he looked like two coat hangers that's
what he looked like man
just a [ __ ] string bean with some
[ __ ] uh styrof what were those
uh styrofoam what were those things
called in kindergarten
that you twist around and they were like
styrofoam
pipe cleaner [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude love when i forget words
that i [ __ ] knew ever since i was a
little kid
[Music]
one just opened up a white claw one fire
um
just [ __ ] did it over the ren or two
he was way and
unreal dude waited for the renter to
drop and he just goes
dude it just
to try and catch it wow
we love white claw dude never had one oh
no
i have oops before i knew what a [ __ ]
white club was
i drank it i thought it was a [ __ ]
energy drink
and i was like the [ __ ] like nine sips
in i was like what the [ __ ]
is this and i looked and it had alcohol
in it so that's the only drinking i've
ever done in my life
is nine sips of white cloth and then
kristen was like do you feel it
for way too long afterwards i'm like
babe i don't feel anything
so we played twitch and it was never my
fault when we did bad
and um
[Music]
but dude these cut scenes they gotta go
man
like just let me jump on a [ __ ] king
king
dragon or whatever the [ __ ] they are in
mario um
and we played and what was i gonna say
about that so follow us on flex avenue
follow follow me on flex avenue i'm
gonna do some more gaming with her
but i'm also gonna do some gaming solo
maybe who knows dude maybe i'm a gamer
now did you ever [ __ ] think of that
stop being on my [ __ ] case maybe i'm
a gamer now
um i forget what i was gonna say but it
was gonna be
something so rad
[Music]
previously on congratulations i'm guy
fieri welcome to dragon balls and
eyesores and
punk [ __ ] that was the rad thing that
i [ __ ] said [ __ ] it i didn't want to
do it i forgot it so that was what it
was anyway
um i don't remember but twitch is pretty
cool
i had fun the screen was small and then
we made it bigger we [ __ ] it up a
little bit
of course i haven't got rid of in one
fire and then one fire came over and was
there and then [ __ ]
left i had no idea [ __ ] just drinking
white claws all the way home
just [ __ ] opening white claws when
the music drops
just waiting listening to siriusxm oop
it's time
sorry little kids but i'mma kill a clown
today
[Music]
i don't know man we got merch up um
on the uh [ __ ] uh
we've got the life rip stuff all out i'm
wearing light right the life rip [ __ ]
right now the shorts dude
these shorts are [ __ ] hell yeah dude
move the chords
tangled
[ __ ] badass dude anyway we lose our
minds babies we lose our minds
let's get to this log cabin so we can
just quit you know
everyone needs to oh i was reading the
tick tock comments and i i stopped
whatever dude it doesn't matter we fly
by the side of our pants on this episode
um yeah so and
oh and we're gonna put the twitch link
in the youtube bio so you can just go
click that and [ __ ]
follow me on twitch on my gamer now um
oh i remembered what the [ __ ] i want to
talk about i had to take a break to
remember it and i can't remember it dude
remember the game [ __ ] goldeneye dude
when i was
when i play who the [ __ ] i stopped
playing video games when you're supposed
to stop playing video games by the way
and that's 23 years old
you're supposed to let it linger after
high school for a little bit that's when
he stopped now one fire's looking at me
like no he's going like this no
and the reason is because he plays
warzone
and he probably also like [ __ ]
literally buys fake video game guns in
the [ __ ] video game
or more more more ammo or some [ __ ]
whatever i don't know
it's dorky to do that people do it fine
he dude he definitely bought a skin
before you know what i mean like what
it's a homer simpson skin
and so uh hey look when he gets killed
um how much was it it was a thousand
dollars
and uh but dude i love that win the game
that's what i'm saying all the cut
scenes bro get them out of here man
remember goldeneye dude goldeneye i
never played a video game more
not goldeneye perfect dark dude that
video game perfect dark with the grenade
launcher
bro i was lethal with the grenade
launcher in perfect dark
i was [ __ ] lethal you couldn't
first of all i couldn't find me
i was like a [ __ ] zit on your back
you can't find me bro
but it hurts it hurts when you do
okay now i didn't realize that that
analogy was going to be so bomb when i
started it but it really was
i'm like is it on your back you can't
find me but when you do it hurts
um yeah dude
and i would just fool across the [ __ ] it
would hit the wall and
you're gone bro you see red and you're
gone that was perfect dark
played it so much played call of duty a
little bit but that was when i was like
all right this ain't no perfect dark and
perfect dark was no gold then i do those
boxy ass james bond guys just running
with the [ __ ] know
with the my with the mind and just here
he goes
boom let it off bro that [ __ ] i was
killing it with that
and then that was it dude but goldeneye
was the [ __ ]
perfect dark was when they lost the
rights to the
james bond franchise they made perfect
dark it's the same game but it's called
perfect dark was on gamecube
i don't even remember not gamecube but
one of those [ __ ]
n64 that's what it was dude i haven't
get rid of coming in
with the [ __ ] dorkiness dude we love
it anyway
man i wonder what it would be like to
play those games again you'd probably be
like it'd probably be like those old
like to not play it now after i was
playing like really good games
it's probably like playing [ __ ] uh
the little thing with the
with these things and the ball goes and
hit between them [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that thing called what
is it pong
yeah and then i played also there was
another version of it later on in
nintendo but anyway who cares you know
that one
arkanoid dark olympics anyway
um arkanoid dude why'd they call it that
dude why'd they call it arkanoid
do you know why they call it arkanoid
dude
yeah but arkanoid dude arkanoid
wow wow i was the arkanoid king
the worst king
um so yeah
you know it was cool to [ __ ] have my
dad on on the episode 200. it was very
cool to have my dad on it was really not
you know i i wasn't sure you know i
don't ever have guests and uh
except for my brother and i thought you
know what 200 i got to do something nice
and fun
and special i thought i did i i thought
about maybe i didn't have to
but um i was like i think i should
eventually and then i asked my dad i was
like would you want to be on
my podcast and he was like sure and i
was like oh hell yeah we got a lot of
[ __ ] to talk about like the calamari
like the tea
like the [ __ ] um
toaster and we got to the hard-hitting
issues man
almost threw up and um my dad uh
my dad and then i posted a clip on it on
instagram and somebody wrote this isn't
funny you've done it before and it
wasn't funny the first time
when you talked about the [ __ ] pasta
how many meats in the pasta
and i was like dude maybe you just don't
like me
why are you following
but we got to the bottom of it dude
basically i get really pent up and
about how people saying certain things
and my dad's saying certain things and
my dad just doesn't give a [ __ ]
he goes okay and i'm just like it can't
seem much
okay um but it was great to have him on
dude i love my family
it was also cool to have my dad on uh
because
you know that's one of those things
where i was like maybe i'll have my dad
on my podcast
and then it's like he's 73 i mean he's
probably gonna live to be [ __ ] 95
with the way he is but
but you know it's like they're getting
older and [ __ ] you ever think about that
oh man i don't need you i don't
i don't want to go down this road but i
did do it oopsie daisy i went down that
road
it's like your parents are just gonna
dude one time i was in therapy when i
used to do
therapy the first time didn't really
stick
i wasn't really listening to her but she
said uh
we were talking about parents dying and
[ __ ] and she was like yeah the only good
thing about your parents dying is that
you don't ever have to
live through that again and i was like
end of the movie with the credits bro
you if you don't get it
i'll explain it after
well the only good thing about your
parents dying is that you never have to
experience again
holy lowly was the lonely places
lonely faces
traces and i think it's kind of funny
funny when it's sad can i find this
lesson
medics in it mad
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] dude [ __ ] it i want to do it
again
well the only thing good about you dude
i'm so annoying man
oh [ __ ] i'm i'm i don't give a [ __ ] dude
oh yeah the only good thing about your
family
dying is that you don't have to [ __ ]
go through it again
as it is again a funny place
sunny traces bunny faces
independent kind of money
doesn't matter
[Music]
and then the camera comes out my [ __ ]
and a new movie starts
[Music]
wow dude if i did mushrooms i would
probably be a teacher or some [ __ ]
like if i did mushrooms like i'm so
already on mushrooms at base that if i
did mushrooms everything would probably
stop and i would just probably be like
so listen here's how you solve stuff
um
oh dude this is the greatest i forgot
about this
did this happen when i was canceled i
did that's why i never talked about the
podcast which is a
[ __ ] sin dude
smokey robinson mispronounces hanukkah
dude remember this
hey marco how you doing surprise
surprise
this is smokey robinson i know you
didn't expect to hear from me
but i was contacted by your sons jeff
and jarrah
and they wanted me they told me that you
used to live in dude why is he
like dude he was like
i mean this is like [ __ ] he was like
when he found out bryant gumbel was
somebody he was like oh you think he's
going to be the guy with the highest
voice
you think brian gumbel's going to be the
[ __ ] with the the black dude
the [ __ ] black dude with the
highest voice well okay i'll beat the
[ __ ] out that [ __ ]
let's join cameo he's like towley dude
oh you think brian campbell's gonna be
the guy with the house voice no
it's gonna be smokey robinson look what
i just did i went hide and brian come on
because brian gumbel will be like real
sports is a real sport
here at the sport of gambling real
sports hey
dude there should have been six episodes
of real sports
now it's like we found
the greatest jumper you know like that's
not a sport
this guy brings samurai swords on every
airplane
why find out real sports what
and it's just some guys like yeah i just
started bringing samurai swords on
planes
and then at the end they'll do the
interview that's what i like about real
sports at the end of the [ __ ] show
they'll interview the guy who
interviewed the guy already
do you know what i mean like it'll be
[ __ ] uh
uh uh brian gumbel interviewing the guy
and then at the end it'll be like brian
gumbel sitting there with another lady
and she'll be like
so why did you do that and brian gump
was like well i thought i should ask him
but i really think
hey i'm smoking robinson let's do it
let's do it again here we go here we go
across the street from me and gosh
that's that's beautiful thank you
thank you how are you doing again i
don't give a [ __ ] nice talking to you
again i guess but anyway you're living
in vancouver
now and they wanted me to wish you happy
chanukah
i
chanukah how do you not know what
hanukkah is chanukah dude
that's what he said
hannah
that's the way he said it
oh my mom forgot
[Laughter]
dude no idea
what chanukah is yeah no [ __ ] happy
chanukah neither do we because they said
so
wait you're living in vancouver now and
they want me to wish you
happy chanukah i have no idea what
chanukah is
but happy chanukah because they said so
anyway god bless you babe and enjoy
chanukah
have a wonderful time i think dude
how somebody says
i only wish all my mistakes were this
charming and innocent
if a white guy made that mistake
somebody will comment he needs to die
you know what i mean oh wow doesn't know
about jews huh
what a privilege that guy must have i
guarantee it
look another person his intentions were
pure but this is still too funny
if it was a white guy he'd be like cut
off his legs he doesn't know what jews
are
i mean dude this is hilarious
anyway all right dude you guys are great
thank you very much um we got the merch
dude we got more merch coming
but uh life rips killed it with the
shorts today thank you very much you're
welcome that was me talking to myself
and um i will also say this man i wanted
to share this with you if you've been on
the road with me
if you've been on the road to see me
before uh my the guy who
uh would open for me michael linoche is
performing in chicago
at the laugh factory august 12th at 8 pm
the tickets are uh
at www.michaellinochi.com
or it's in his instagram bio and he told
me to say that i'm sure so you'll
[ __ ] follow him on instagram that
[ __ ] but um it's all good go see
him in chicago
at the laugh factory chicago factory and
uh
that's michael noche's gonna be there so
that's cool go support uh the homie
uh and i think that that's it that's all
i wanted to talk about but thanks very
much you guys
uh sayonara oh also uh uh before i even
say sayonara there's that new uh
we're doing a new segment on uh on on
patreon that we're doing uh that you can
uh watch it and it's called
why you'd want me to say it's on patreon
why though
oh yeah i gotta sell it more okay no
you're right i gotta sell it more watch
how i do it watch out go in sell mode
hey guys
you guys tired of not having segments
well check this out there's a new
segment and it's called
review mode starring me crystalia
and what you got to do is sign up for
the patreon
and i review all sorts of unbestankable
crazy [ __ ] dude
i do crazy [ __ ] i review movie trailers
cars [ __ ] shirts who [ __ ] i review
everything man i see pictures and stuff
and i go
hey man that should be like this or this
should be like that dude
you're gonna want to [ __ ] get
unsubscribing on my patreon
so you can get this new segment dude
just more conf
content for that ass i'm sorry little
kids
but i'mma kill a clown today hey guys
that's the episode for that ass on
youtube
if you want to see the rest of the
episode for that ass it's on patreon
so just go on over to my patreon that's
patreon.comcrystalia
and you could sign up and not only get
the rest of this episode
but also all of the other patreon
episodes that are only on patreon
and also all of the other rest of the
episodes that are on youtube
anyway dude there's so much content
patreon.com
crystalia see you there
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
should i change my shirt should i do a
different shirt with the cause i just
did it with the
no